are on yes okay good
welcome folks we will not spend too long
doing introduction any things because
there's a lot to get through on Monday
evening meds and I were talking in
Copenhagen and we talked for three and a
half hours though there was a bit of a
break in there and we don't have three
and a half hours today and we're still
trying to cover pretty much the same set
of features and things yeah there's a
lot to tell and we're not going to even
scratch the surface of c-sharp eight
really because for one thing there's a
lot that we don't well I don't really
know yet about what's going to happen
we're going to focus on the bits of
c-sharp eight that our preview ball
which means you can get it right now
although I wouldn't suggest downloading
it over conference Wi-Fi very very
briefly I'm John skeet I'm a c-sharp
developer in Google cloud platform there
are other Google cloud platform speakers
go see awesome things mats you want to
introduce yourself I'm Matt Ferguson I
gave the keynote this morning they
introduced me there and I also don't
have a slide with other Microsoft people
doing talks so this is highly
asymmetrical and I'm already miffed but
there are many and you should go see
them all yeah but I'm the lead designer
of c-sharp and I have been really
burning to talk about C sharp all
morning and now I finally get to sew so
let's go cool so I have various demos
the the demo bits for both Noble
reference types and for persons are the
same demos that you will see if you
watch Justin Ahmed's do their build talk
but given that it's me and Mads run
Dustin Ahmed's will probably have a
different kink on things and in
particular I've got another solution
which shows what happened when I tried
to use nullable reference types and some
of the weirdnesses that I found so yeah
I get to rag on Mads a bit on sage live
is it's great but easy to point out so
it's been a whole week of that yeah we
apologize by the way for people who are
near the front on the sides we will try
to explain what we're doing so
if you can't see the screen you'll still
have some kind of idea is this big
enough by the way font wise does anyone
need it to be bigger yeah okay I'm
getting thumbs up from the back yes so
we will try to explain it audibly Mads
will do interpretive dance and nullable
reference types and you know through the
the mixed-media hopefully we'll get the
get the ideas flowing so mats you want
to give the big picture what do we
picture well so I I cleverly set it up a
little in the keynote this morning if
you were on the site that could hear I
hear that there were problems with the
sound on one side of the stage but
essentially yes no no reference
exceptions are usually not popular
sometimes there's a show of hands like
how many people love null reference
exceptions and there's always a few and
that's how you know who to avoid in the
hallway but but generally having the
null reference exception is not fun
because then you have to chase down
where it came from and why you have it
and who's to blame and it's not the
nulls are bad it's just that you want to
really say when to use them and when not
to write so the whole idea is that we
want to retrofit a notion onto my onto a
c-sharp about when it's a good idea to
have an Allison when it's not a good
idea and then we want to enforce it and
in fact that the idea of there are
things that are sometimes good sometimes
bad and we just want to let people be
able to express their ideas that's sort
of true of all of programming language
features it's all about you you have
your ideas how can we make you express
them where you couldn't before or
express them more concisely and if you
start looking at every new language
feature and right what is that letting
me express better more expressed that I
couldn't express before things start to
fall into place a bit more yep let's get
to a demo so we have a really simple
class it has first name middle name last
name some what sort of western-centric
here but leaving that aside so these are
all strings we have two constructors one
takes just the first name and the last
name
and leaves the middle name property
specified here yeah we we don't
initialize it explicitly and so you know
behind the scenes we know that means
it'll be null and then we try to use
this so if we if we try to do this with
me I would use Mads but I don't know his
middle name and I probably wouldn't be
able to spell it if you told me yes I
don't know I don't actually have one oh
well okay Leslie from now on so we can
I'll just call the method rather than
using the results so you know we can we
can get my middle name and in fact I can
just write it and if we execute this
code this bits gonna be fine because
we've got this get length the middle
name method that just returns P dot
middle name dot length so we're dotting
in two things and that will be fine for
me and it will return six and when it'll
print six and then we talk about Miguel
de Icaza now this demo isn't meant to
imply that wherever Miguel goes there
are problems and you know he causes
trouble and things that's just the
corollary but as soon as we do try to
use Miguel as an example we will get a
null reference exception yeah this is
this is expected now this is the slight
problem so I've got two different
versions of visual well I've got three
different versions of Visual Studio
effectively installed in different hives
with different V sixes and things so
anyway it can take a little while but
hopefully you can all see we get the NRI
that you would expect so the whole point
of this feature is to try to avoid that
how can we find out that that was going
to happen right out having to run the
code right I think that one I mean one
important thing here is that if you look
at this little tiny example you can't
you know that it's wrong but you can't
really point to one line of code and say
that's the code that's the line that's
wrong it all depends right what's it
supposed to be now was I supposed to
have checked you know it's it's not
clear yes and because express the
expressiveness isn't yeah yeah now
unfortunately for a tool you
if Visual Studio is going to give us an
error then it does have to pin down you
where where is something going to be
wrong and it has chosen in this case the
constructor so this is using the C sharp
8 preview and that's assuming that
anytime you refer to a reference type in
its normal form that should always be
non null at least by the time you know
by the time we exit the constructor all
the properties and fields should be non
null and if we have parameter of string
that should be non null etc etc right so
to interject something here we are
changing the meaning of reference types
in c-sharp and a little bit which is
quite scary which is a little scary and
which is part of the reason why we
haven't gone near this feature for the
decade that it's been discussed have you
thought of maybe making integer literals
hex by default yeah that would be a big
breaking chain right but the reason we
chose to do it like that is that we
don't want to just do it with all new
syntax where everything works the way it
used to because the whole point of the
feature is to point out places where you
code is vulnerable and your existing
code is probably vulnerable in a lot of
places and we want the feature to be
useful to find those places as well and
and go and put annotations and null
checks in until you're good so it has to
work on existing code but it is only
warnings and it is the first language
feature in c-sharp that is that has an
opt-in flag right so you'll be able to
say don't give me those warnings I'm not
ready to deal with it or I think your
whole nullable thing is stupid you get
to not do it right I don't not doing is
quite subtle and the details are yet to
be fleshed out of exactly yeah if you
use a prototype it always does it
because we weren't prototyping the user
experience of how to turn it off yes but
we will at some point yeah
and it's complicated because you may be
writing a library and you're starting to
experiment with it but maybe you're not
ready to say this is null safe this is
sort of fully baked or maybe you are
ready to say that because you believe
everything's right but you haven't yet
actually fixed up everything internally
or you may be consuming that library so
there are all kinds of different
approach that we're still working on but
actually let's show the feature lets
show ya and and then we can talk about
the things that aren't there so let's
try you'll if you try to apply the
feature to your existing code it is like
playing whack-a-mole and so we will play
whack-a-mole
in front of you right now so it's saying
it's uninitialized so let's initialize
it let's yeah stupid visual studio
doesn't know that things are going to be
null okay
I've moved the error it is now
initialized but it's initialized to
something that it's not meant to be so
just to read the warning out to you it's
saying cannot convert no literal to non
nullable reference or unconstrained type
parameter which is you see sharps
becky's for you're getting it wrong so
what are we trying to express here Mads
yeah something's wrong but yes what's
wrong so the thing about assuming that
reference types as they are today no
longer can have null is that we also
need to let you express when they can
have null and so that's where this new
syntax or rather existing syntax that
you can apply in your places right you
guys we now have nullable reference
types and that is why that is what the
feature is called we call it nullable
reference types because that's what's
the bit that has nuisance yes so so we
want to make the middle name nullable
because we're saying you if we're only
saying you can provide two things in
this constructor yeah we could make it
default to an empty string and that's
one way of getting everything out and
that may be a choice that you would make
in this particular case that's an
entirely reasonable choice and the
compiler can't possibly tell whether
that's the right choice for you or
making it nullable it would be a really
boring demo if we just left it here and
said okay so yeah we're not actually
going to show you how you know Abul
reference types yes so we'll take the
opposite yes the whole point is that you
get you get to choose B this forces you
to think about what is my design here
what should i do when there is no middle
name yeah it makes you make a deliberate
decision and stick to it rather than
just have whatever happened to be there
when you went home for the day right and
this is how you make that decision
it's a single character change we're
making middle name a nullable string
property right so whenever you get if
you call person dot first name the the
compiler has said if you have fixed
everything up and it's not it's not a
firm guarantee it's not like a guarantee
of you know if you fetch this it
definitely definitely won't return you
something that isn't a string it's not
going to return you a button or
something that's really fully baked into
the CLR it could return you know but if
everyone's behaved nicely
it won't yeah okay so there's a certain
amount of this is a trust system and
honor system whereas middle name it's
saying you know what you really need to
be careful now because this could be
null it's it's making a polite
suggestion to where it's consuming it
that they better be careful right Island
and that polite suggestion has indeed
gone we've we fixed the initialization
error right and we have a different
problem somewhere else so now the
consumer of this API they get presented
with a different public surface area and
these question marks you know travel
with the signatures across assembly
boundaries and now we see the question
mark on this side of the compiler does
and it says it says possible dereference
of a null reference mm-hmm okay this
time not so much you're doing it wrong
as you might be doing it wrong there's
this is a bit of danger so note that
it's not saying that P might be null
because P here is a value of type person
non-noble person it's saying that in
fact it's the squiggle is in slightly
the wrong place it should be on this dot
that isn't covered by the squiggles yes
I think that's probably right that's the
bit that's potentially wrong but it's
not all kinds of do referencing that
have syntax we can put space I
absolutely think we're trying to be
consistent here yeah so this is the
things that I can be my excuse but with
nd referencing all right so what can we
do about that we can you know what do we
want to return if someone has no middle
names what do you think what if you
don't have a middle name what's the
length
zero okay we can do that so we'll use
the null conditional operator which
works just as well as it always has and
so the value of this expression sorry
that the static type for this expression
is now null int and we can just use null
coalescing operator and or of course we
could have returned we could have
changed the signature of the method and
and propagated it back but that you know
so now when we run it we should no
longer get the exception 6 which was
from my middle name and 0 for Miguel so
the thing to realize here is you didn't
have to do a new kind of thing to tell
to convince the compiler that there
wasn't a null here and so unlike many
systems that have sort of null
resilience built in from the start they
could just have the only way you can
check for null in those systems and get
a value the only way you could get a
value out is if you check for null first
like it's sort of built-in whether it's
done with pattern matching or something
similar by construction you can't do
reference until you've ruled out the
possibility that there's a null you can
only do reference into a body of code
where it's known not to be known and we
don't want we could do that in c-sharp
in fact pattern matching will do that
for you in c-sharp but we don't want to
force you to write your code in your way
the whole point of this is finding out
whether your existing code is good and
helping you fix it in the ways you've
always fixed it in there about a million
or maybe twelve there abouts different
ways you're checking for null today or
making sure something's not null and we
try to recognize all of those by doing a
flow analysis on the body of the of the
code that is using the denali ball
references which brings up an
interesting point about it's not just
it's not as simple as it sounds like it
might be so let's let's try to extract
this if this expression is far too long
let's let's try to extract some locals
so if we do string middle equals P dot
middle name that should give us a
warning because hey that's not that
that's none of all and this is non
nullable so we can say okay we've got a
nullable local variable and then we can
say should I use that the
schools in touch you can show new
schools interpreting of them so if we
use this we can return null sorry return
zero there now what should happen if I
do middle dot length as after this check
if this were a simple feature that the
compiler thought okay well the type of
middle is still nullable string
therefore any time you dot into it you
know we need to warn you then this would
not compile but that would be I'll give
you a less useful sorry yeah it would
give you a warning and that would be
less useful so effectively the fact that
you can see there are no scribbles here
the compiler keeps for each is it just
for local variables no it's for local
variables and a lot of names as well
right okay if you had done it with
directly with Peter middle name instead
of having it that would still work
essentially whichever way you do it
right up to a certain point like we
track essentially the flow analysis
tracks current null ability for a given
point in code for a given for any given
variable that is either a simple or a
dotted name right does it more
efficiently than that but but that's
essentially it
yeah and so in this danger here just
yeah it's a highlight that suppose your
middle name property either someone was
messing with it in a different thread or
it was a bizarre property like date time
now is a bizarre property because it
changes value all the time maybe P dot
middle name uses date time now and says
if the second of the minute is zero it
will return you null otherwise it will
return you something non null then you
could easily still get a null reference
exception here right the idea is to
protect you from the 80% of bugs or
probably more like nineteen so this is
one of many ways in which there the null
warning system isn't precise and can't
be and we just have to live with that
but it's still we hope it was still
pretty good and a lot a large part of it
is not so much about does it catch
everything
it's about making you make those
deliberate decisions we're having the
expressiveness around it then the rest
usually falls out pretty well yeah it
has a corner case it's probably the best
example I've seen of the C sharp team
being pragmatic rather than dogmatic so
we've seen that in in other places as
well glad you don't say first no
definitely not so another example would
be a sink and a weight that you a sink
methods in c-sharp v always returned
tasks or tasks of T or void it's like
well ah that's not not as general as it
could be yeah but do you know what it
does the job and okay it's generalized
more in c-sharp 7 in a way that most
people won't use um other than using
value tasks but we did pretty well for a
long time since what 2013 something like
that yeah and when you were saying about
1968 versus 1967 for similar it's like
visual studio year numbers aren't always
necessarily the same as calendars so
you're building from the best I guess
yeah yeah that's one of the main lessons
we took from at okay so we have been 20
minutes we've got a few minutes are
there any other points about no ability
that you particularly want to hit I
think you had one that you wanted to get
into right right so there's one
interesting idea here in terms of is it
reference equality yeah
so I demonstrated before that if you if
you check whether something is null if
you do if text is null then the compiler
knows after that that text length is
fine but this is just one way of
checking whether it's null another would
be to use reference equals text no and
suddenly we get squiggles yes because
the compiler doesn't know that reference
equals checks for equality and a method
call exactly and another example would
be in string dot is no loyalty next so
if string dot is null or empty returns
true then it might be no yeah this
should be might be but if it returns
false then it definitely isn't and I was
concerned until Monday evening that
either we'd end up with situations where
we would know that something was non
null but we would have to tell the
compiler we knew better than that better
than it did which is like that's what a
cast always is it's saying I know more
than you do and every time you do that
that's a source of potential for you
being wrong so I want to avoid that as
far as possible we we do have that yes
we do it's a good opportunity which I
don't know I would really like it if
this stayed officially as the dammit
operator
my guess is you're not gonna be allowed
no we are based in America we can we
can't call it that oh it was based in
Europe so yes we can call it the damnit
operator yeah so text dammit it's a it's
no no it's a postfix exclamation mark
that says whatever null ability warnings
you were about to give here compiler
don't give me those warnings because I
know exactly what I'm doing so you can
also call it D I know what I'm doing
already there this will be on my
tombstone but you know it has many names
my favorite example of it when I was
applying all of this denoted time was if
you're checking if you're calling a
method that says it shouldn't accept a
non novel reference if you're writing a
library you should still be checking
whether it's not or not because someone
might be using an old compiler or might
be disabling things etc so you should
still be checking you should throw an
argument null exception and so no time
is a good citizen it does so and I
wanted tests to check that so how do you
how do you knowingly pass null and
convince the compiler that it's okay and
you write that you do something like
console dot write line no oh damn it
this is really not now or at least I
want you to ignore the fact that it
really is no um however so but that's
not the reason why you stopped being
returned Monday night right
going back to this so my concern was
that either we would end up having to
use the damnit operator far more than we
wanted to or that the compiler would
have built into it this is what
reference equals does this is what
string dot is null or empty does and
those are different things so string dot
is null or empty you know returns true
or false and that's part of it
reference equals it's only useful if you
know that one side of it is null because
if it's just if reference equals XY then
whether that returns true or false you
don't know whether X or Y are null you
know there'd be that they are the same
degree of null right and there are there
are other things there are methods that
if you pass in null it will return null
if you pass in non null it will return
non null so all the cast operators in
link to XML you can cast a null x
element reference to string and it will
return string it's sort of null
propagating methods player I think their
generic things as well where you have
the you have some of the link operators
like first or default
mm-hmm that says in the method name I
don't care what your word your elements
are but I might return an all right
right so if you if you use that with an
unknowable element type you still get
nulls right so the list is pretty long
but but you can make an excessive list I
think of the sort of 98 99 percent of
special null behaviors that are out
there for methods and then you can
create a little little language in
attributes that's what we are currently
working on of attribute said you can put
a message to say this method has special
null behavior either you know it returns
a boolean and that affects this
particular parameter but your attribute
on or the whole method is an equality
method or things like that so we can we
can make that little language and then
you can use it or and we can use it in
in our libraries and use that the
compiler can know about that language we
just about the specific about the
specific method because I'm not going to
submit a pull request to Rosalyn saying
please be aware of these no design
methods thought I still want to be I
still want the compiler to be aware of
where
I have special null handling so I was
very pleased to hear that there will be
this this little language and that
certain little plan but in the prototype
that's fine that's fine
cool I said we should stop nullity in
about 25 minutes
it is exactly oh it's now 26 minutes
sorry so we should look at patterns okay
I have the other can I say something
about patterns we're in the old coat
that you had there yeah did you close it
you closed it but I've got something
similar in the other one it's just do
you yeah yeah you do the comparison here
right actually comparing comparing to
null with the equals equals is it's a
bit of a smell and you will have because
you have the risk that somebody has
overloaded the Equality operator and
they actually do something other than
you would expect them to usually if it's
a good override of the Equality operator
it will still deal well with null and
you'll get this one you might using the
stringer but you might be you you might
be executing a lot of user code to get
to that yeah um so actually since
c-sharp seven oh this is a little trick
the way that at least I recommend I
don't have to put it into the guidelines
head checking for null is to use the is
operator because the is operator now
takes patterns and one of the patterns
is the constant pattern and in all is a
constant and so by using pattern
matching here to check through the is
keyword whether it's null that goes
another route that doesn't let you plug
in user code and indeed make sure that
you are checking that the reference is
null not running through some some
custom stuff actually one of the site
benefits there's another feature that's
being discussed to be able to combine
patterns you know if this pattern or
this pattern which would be potentially
with keywords of or and and and maybe
not and if we have that as well then we
can be you know almost like single now
you could have if something is not know
person's so that's yeah that's that one
so I'm down to one Visual Studio open
that's that's always good okay it's gone
faster and faster notice we're speaking
faster as well as we're releasing
processing cycles here so patterns yeah
do you know should we show the person
you show that the types involved first
so we have a person that's base class
with first name and last name a
professor is a person some students may
disagree but a professor is a person who
also has a subject and a student is a
person that professors like a student is
a person who also has a professor and
they're all done simply and I would
point out the yeah there's a little
person here that if you haven't seen
before it's lovely
where a constructor if it's just
assigning properties or fields one neat
way of doing it is to use a couple on
the right-hand side and deconstruction
on the left-hand side and matza shows me
that the compiler is smart enough to
avoid creating the tupple I need to
verify this at some point and what I
particularly like about this is in the
person class we've got not only a
constructor but a Deconstructor and the
Deconstructor looks exactly the same as
a constructor but slightly reversed
which you know makes the whole name work
really really well mm-hmm
so yeah we did think about it a little
bit nice pattern so net yeah because you
know actually initially when we added
expression body members we didn't even
add them for constructors because like
who has a constructor of only of only
one statement you typically have a
number of assignments but once we had
deconstruction in there all of a sudden
this pattern became possible and now it
you know it's a whole pattern you made
like you know you may not but it's a
whole pattern where you can initialize
your whole object in one expression and
then just make it an expression body and
there you go off to the races I love it
too and it kind of in terms of why you
would do it it's not because it saves
you a couple of lines of code but it
does when you look at that you know all
this constructor is doing is a sign
proxy's yeah that's kind of all it can
do because the only statement is an
assignment statement right so I like
what you do if you do anything other
than pass for Amazon on the right hand
side if you start having logic like oh
that parameter and multiply it by the
other parameter or anything like that
then I wouldn't do it any more because
then one thing it does is it removes the
assignee and the and the value from each
other a little too much for there being
anything fancy going on the one
exception I might make to that is
calling a method that validates that
something's not not sure okay but maybe
yes okay simple to do with just the one
value we've negotiated right so we
should talk about patterns patterns
that's right came from and this is the
only useful method we're just calling
yeah we're just calling this method
we'll focus on this method right so
there are two things we want to well
there are several things we want to do
with patterns and we sort of happy to
take patterns a bit at a time from
release to release once we know how the
previous batch kind of played out and
the next round includes a few things
first of all it's it's all hunky-dory
though you have a slightly different
assembly that's still fine it's all that
you have a what's that it's the one
Dustin gave me is it yeah anyway
so using switch statements can sometimes
be a bit of a pain it's actually not too
bad here because you're calling returned
in all these places and so you don't
have to say break and so it kind of
saves you a line for every case but I
imagine that you had a variable that you
need to get the string into and do
something else with after then you have
to assign to the variable and then do
the break and it gets a little more
cumbersome but either way we decided
it's time to have a switch expression in
c-sharp that's the same pretty much as a
switch statement except the syntax is
nicer and it works with expressions okay
so we could instead of running the
switch here we could we could just
return a switch expression and then
whatever gets chosen gets
turned so the way it looks is the syntax
we're thinking of is sort of an infix
notation because that's more expression
e where you say person switch and then
curly braces and then you have your
cases inside of the switch end it with a
semicolon like usual and now it's
complaining a little bit that it can't
figure out the type of this switch
expression because there's nothing
inside of it so we need to put something
inside away so let's start doing that we
can just just take them from the top we
we don't want to make you put the the
case keyword in there we saw it's always
gonna be that white why bother making
you repeat something that's not always
going to be there the colons there's so
many things in expressions that have
colons we figured it would look red a
little nicer with the with the fed arrow
but we're willing to discuss we actually
changed our minds like a couple of days
before we ship the prototype on that so
can change again but that's what the
that's what a conditioned part of it
looks like and then you just put instead
of a statement you put it just put an
expression on on the right hand side
there so we can take that ik o did I do
something that copying is apparently
very help yeah must do is it formatting
my my clipboard who days when I was
anyway so so that's all that a case
looks like right pattern fat arrow
expression and then a comma separated
because again feels more expression e
and we can do the other ones single
lioness there so we can say student s
fat arrow at least you have the same
keyboard as I do so that's the wrong one
oh yeah yeah right and you've missed the
teal student just too before it starts
complaining us as too much I did as well
and I was just saying how nice it is
that a keyboard I can actually use but
apparently not student and to step into
the role of Dustin there will be
glorious refactorings that make all of
this easy yeah having done tens of these
at least manually it gets kind of
frustrating yeah
so again just a prototype the for the
for the
in case there's actually a wind clause
in the in the switch statement but which
is not part of the pattern which is part
of the case and those are also available
in the in the expression syntax even
walnuts types just that aspect of when
is not part of the pattern and I found
it useful when I've been learning about
patterns to separate out in my mind what
patterns are available so there are type
matching patterns will show you property
matching patterns there are constant
patterns and var persons is that it or I
missed no that might be it so there are
kinds of patterns and then there are the
places you can apply them which are if
statements or boolean conditions and
switch statements and now switch
expressions and each of those may well
very may well be augmented independently
but if you think of them as orthogonal
things then as soon as you've learned oh
there's a new kind of pattern you know I
can apply it in these places so just
that's a learning yeah tricking yep so
this switch statement was already being
a bit modern also in that instead of
having a default it had a case
underscore which is the new discard
pattern and it's used elsewhere as well
and that indeed is the only way that you
can provide a default clause you don't
get to say default in a switch but
that's so this is really just syntax
it's just it reached nicer this way at
least I think so but yeah you mileage
may vary it's it's a bit of a I mean
it's a bit of a big expression here with
the long strings and so on but no not
too bad so switch expressions that's one
thing can we get it old compiled by
getting rid of this down yeah then we
can take the unreachable code and yep so
there we go and I just I feel on a bound
to then turn it into an expression body
member just Mads isn't as keen on this
as I am but I I wanted to do this every
time I when I watched
the the build thing is hey why didn't
you turn it now it's just one expression
why are you still using a return
statement this is just lovely right but
this isn't we haven't shown any new
persons we were going to say about
persons yes what's going on with that
well the the thing we're thinking for
the next bit of pattern matching is that
it'd be nice if you could have patterns
to go a little deeper alright so we have
these type patterns and we could maybe
make them smarter we do we we take we
give a name to the thing we we get when
when the type check is true and then we
we just dot into this name for different
things we fish them out what if we could
as part of the pattern we could get at
those so that's what the two different
kinds of recursive patterns what they're
for
so in the person pattern let's start
with the person in the type pattern you
can put for instance what we call a
property pattern so that starts with a
curly and ends with a curly and inside
you can start talking about the
properties of person there's fields and
properties okay so if I start typing you
see I get completion I can talk about
the first name of the item I'm
interested in the last name here
for my condition so I can say last name
colon and then apply a pet now I can put
a pattern I can apply a pattern to the
last name for instance I can apply the
constant pattern and use the Campbell
constant and put it there instead and
now I essentially took that when clause
and make it made it obsolete because I'm
just applying the pattern that checks
for the exact value of the of the last
name I'm applying that directly where
that came from
there we go so that's one way of doing
it right and now I we could get the
first name as well
yes we could yeah you want to just to
just to you know go all out you might
may or may not want to but we say the
first name the all we want with the
first name is we want to grab it so we
can use it later and you and the Gravatt
pattern is the VAR pattern which always
works right which is probably worth
highlighting actually in this particular
case so yeah so Mazdas changing instead
of tossing in the first name
here we can just use FN now now if
you're someone who has strong opinions
about I don't want to use var I want to
use string it's worth understanding that
in this particular case changing varta
string makes a difference yes because
the vowel pattern always matches
whatever the value is the type pattern
only matches for non audible reference
types at least I don't know what would
happen if you did a string question mark
in there I mean in this preview of
homework there's I think we won't allow
it
right because the nullable nullable
types are not supposed to have any
semantic impact right anywhere they only
give you warnings or not okay so so if
we change this to string FN then it
won't match if the first name is null
okay so we're we're you've trained your
brain to say I can change var to the
type of the the thing that I'm looking
at at any time that's not the case for
patterns right okay you can essentially
say var is in nullable version of it and
will always accept and just give you
infer the type and give you a name for
it right I know we don't need P now you
don't need P so now you get to alight
that because nobody's using it anymore
you don't have to give the whole thing a
name and actually because the thing that
comes in is type this person you can
also light the the type to begin with
and it's still the type pattern even
though it now has none of the elements
of the type pattern that the previous
type pattern has right it's just
abbreviating different things and you
don't have to you know you can still put
the person there if you find that more
readable I'm uncertain on this I think
it's one of those things that you need
to use and find out yeah and I mean this
is an example that society designed to
go a little overboard with these things
right so so let's go overboard let's
yeah let's try it myself so I haven't
played with this nearly as much as
Matt's hair so I may well make some
mistakes here okay but let's let's try
doing exactly the same kind of thing
with a student but we want to be able to
pass a match to get the last name
instead so I'm going to pass a match and
the only bit of the the pattern that's
really
doing matching conditionally rather than
grabbing is the student part so we we're
not expecting to have anything in here
that in the property part that won't
match and so I can save our last or Ln
to be consistent with what Mads has
already done and then the advisor well I
guess there's one thing if I do
what are we printing out the advisors
last name okay and that make that as our
yeah oh hey Ellen for adviser last name
yeah yeah now I think this this has
actually changed the the meeting
slightly oh it was actually is the first
name who's got the that was work were
young you got young name for the year
and so this isn't quite a refactoring
because we're avoiding a null reference
exception here because yes pattern won't
match if the student doesn't have an
advisor whereas previously it would have
matched and then the interpolated string
that the type pattern in all its forms
never matches a null right which is
actually if I can do it can I do a lot
of course um yeah so indentations gone a
bit wonky which is almost certainly my
fault somewhere it doesn't matter you
can handle it right don't get dizzy and
fall off the cliff here because it's
very steep but again you're no regions
you know so it's interesting that since
the type pattern never matches null
mm-hm
you can actually use it as a match
everything except null pattern well of
course you could say you know it's
persons you could say I'm person P
already before matched everything except
in all and it was only because we had a
condition on top of it that I didn't
match everything but with the new
Curly's and with you being able to make
everything else optional and alighted
you could actually say we only want to
say come back last year to somebody who
is someone so the curly open curly close
curly is a special case but all it means
is
if you're not null I match right it's
saying oh I'm checking you at the type
that you're already at so I lighted the
type and I'm going to check for all
these zero properties that the patterns
on the match oh they all did so all
right so all now left to do is to see
whether your null anon so this
presumably will now fail to we'll get a
warning somewhere because this isn't
exhaustive so that gives me a chance to
show that off you see now there's a
warning on the switch which says hey as
far as we can see this switch expression
is next sauced if it's not it you know
there are certain values for which it
wouldn't match anything and that's a
little worse in an expression than in a
statement because her statement it's
fine to do things you don't do anything
for but for an expression you want some
kind of result and actually and it's so
it's so bad to do this that it only
gives you a squiggly as a warning but
then the compiler has an internal error
and fails to emit valid il and my guess
is that that may change before no that's
how we punish you right okay so it's
it's just it checks actually for the
username so no so the it's only a
warning because sometimes that's
surprising and what people want well so
that's gonna stay as a warning I think I
had fully expected that that would
become an error I think so also I think
there might be cases where we can't tell
I mean similar to null there might be
cases where you know but it doesn't know
life like that because actually figuring
out figuring out exhaustive Ness it's
pretty exhausting so if so my personal
plea here this is back to like paying on
Monday night so what I've done in loads
of cases I have this a lot of the time
so in no time I've got a phone interview
lure some zone mapping so if you've got
a local time that might map to zero one
or two instance in time depending on
whether you're in a daylight saving
transition one way or another or just
normal and I have a switch statement
that says what's the count 0 1 or 2 and
then I've got to have a default and
thrown you in valid operation exception
right if the compiler just inserts throw
new invalid
operation exception no unmatch switch
pattern or whatever then yeah I can
delete more code yes and the idea is
that it will throw an exception there
also so the runtime semantics are
falling through to the end of a switch
expression is that an exception gets
thrown right
it could be invalid operation exception
as well just maybe I don't know if we've
decided which one yet
but makes sense that it's that one so
but in order to silence this warning now
we could we could go and use the
underscore now as a catch-all and say
you know sorry you are no one there's no
discrimination yeah let's put the comma
there to make it happy but just to make
clear that it really only is null that
didn't fall through yet after I used
that curly trick we can we can do it
just for null and see that we still
don't get the warning back like well
compiler really knew when it got here
you could see that we dealt with
everything except null so it's being
pretty it's been pretty smart about the
exhaustive mess but it it took me okay
after several months to get it right so
cool there we are there's one more kind
of recursive pattern go for it I was
just thinking well yeah you cover
Pathan's
much quicker than we took over an hour
to questions and things so one of the
things you notice is that all of these
types have deconstructors on them which
is pretty new thing which lets you plug
into the deconstruction yep okay I
personally don't recommend that you do
that everywhere because if it's if you
do it just to get values out of your
type then member access is much better
but if your type really is sort of tuple
like and you often want everything and
the ordering will be entirely clear to
everyone ordering makes sense the
ordering is part of it yeah can you
really remember which order those three
ents are those is different different
type I guess if you've got the go style
of you know success or not and the
result hmm so they're going to be a
different type and if you get them round
in the wrong order then your type system
will complain it
you anyway then that's probably not so
bad but the danger and the allure of the
positional approach if you will is that
you have to remember the order but then
you don't have to say the names and so
you get to say things shorter shorter
when in order that's like a little so
why don't we think of that also in terms
of patterns that dichotomy here we're
doing the property patterns nay in a
name based way we say the name of that
property apply a pattern to it and so
forth but maybe we when we have
deconstructors on the types why can't we
applied the deconstructors and do the
patterns on in order on what comes back
from that Deconstructor right and indeed
we can so let's do that for the last
example up here the professor which not
surprisingly we do the the deconstruct
pattern using friends and we want the
last name and the subject and I seem to
remember that professors order was first
name last name subject okay
so we can ignore the first name with the
underscore which you can't see because
it's red squiggly then we can get the
last name and we can get the subject for
instance okay something like this and
that is a very concise way of sucking
out some values and and using them later
which we didn't get to the using them
later part well now and it's it makes it
yeah nice and terse but also just that
little bit harder to maybe yeah just a
pair of six and a variable names maybe
let me let me just check that I
understand it properly and this is
genuine this is not me sort of faking it
so that one just grabbed the values but
presumably we can use this in the same
way as the property pattern that
sometimes we're grabbing sometimes we're
doing things conditional yeah yeah yeah
so I can do and can I replace the whole
of the property person with just just
this without specifying the type so
string FN yeah and Kemble yep so you can
hang on don't delete right
this works without you deleting anything
because what you have to think about is
that these patterns the way that we
decided on the syntax was as much
analogy as possible to construction when
we're matching against something it's
like we're deconstructing it can we are
conditionally deconstructing it and
therefore if it looks the same as when
you're constructing things that's nice
when you construct an object you can you
say new you have the type which in a
later release might become optional you
optionally have some constructor
parameters and then you optionally have
a an object initializer yep
and you can have all of those if you
want to and the same way in a in a tight
pattern you can have both if you really
want to you can have both discard there
and discard here yes and so this is the
this is the grabbing parties you can't
just leave them yeah so this is the
grabbing part and this is the matching
part yeah I don't think I'm gonna be
using that no but it's just pointing out
the generality oh yeah unless there are
bits we're deconstructing gives me some
things and there are some bits so with
the professor one yeah we have the D
constructor that that gives you all
three but if we only have the two of
them then we could deconstruct to get
the last name and things I don't think
it's going to be common to use both not
at least principle is is a useful one to
make things as impossible as possible
yeah
and that's sort of making the the fact
that it's commas here rather than
semicolons because that's how you
express a sequence of things so this is
like a collection initializer for a
switch is like here are the patterns
within the switch yeah it sort of takes
a little while but then you think yeah
that is entirely natural
so there's actually something you can do
in let's see you know I can't no I don't
have a good example over here yeah
actually I do there's something you can
do in in ordinary deconstruction for
ordinary variable declarations and so on
which is that you can put a you can sort
of effect to the VAR outside right and
you just have variable declarations
inside and you can also do that in
patterns I just can't remember if we
implemented it yet for this prototype
but I think we can do this let's see if
it works yes but then you can't have
then you can have the then show you so
it's a variant of the VAR pattern
actually you know much if the first name
is null when it wouldn't have done
before no so it's a little inconsistent
maybe we should allow it with the curly
braces as well actually and we'll have
to discuss that okay right you get to
factor the VAR outside of the
Deconstructor thing if you don't also
have to say a type there but it's a
little right special Casey this is this
is a pleasure for you I normally when
I'm doing a talk and I talk very very
quickly and leave at least some people's
minds go I don't understand I know you
get to see exactly the same thing with
meals actually it's not a parent works
just in a couple of minutes because I I
have something else to show as well we
should talk about the other features of
c-sharp 8 that might happen you know
everything right i I guess you're pretty
confident that these nullable and switch
expressions and and pattern matching
extensions will will happen right and
there's one more feature that is also
actually in prototype it's in the same
prototype which is what's it was that
what you wanted to be it wasn't okay
yeah which is about indexes and ranges
so we want to make sure sharp a little
more expressive when it comes to talking
about both indexing into data structures
and and also looking at windows to see
sort of sub sections of things so we
want to support in the language
expressing indices that are also from
the end indices and normally integers
and also there's expressing ranges one
of the motivators for it is the span of
T stuff that has already happened in the
language so I don't you want to go or
should I
yeah okay let's be reasonable yeah but
yeah just quickly well it's really
annoying sometimes when you want to look
at the last thing you have to do the
arithmetic and make sure you're not off
by one and so on so we actually now has
syntax for getting the last element so I
can just say hat one and people with
like regular expressions you typically
complain about our choice of hat but it
is oh because it would normally mean the
start yeah fantastic finally I have a
way of remembering because I always get
confused which is dollar and witch's hat
and if I remember that it's the opposite
of what c-sharp does then well people
who love but that's how I'm going to
room it would be even easier if we had
the dollar sign but you know what
this isn't set in stone but that is what
we went with for the prototype yep so
and and the nice thing about it it's not
like a part of the index or syntax or
something like that it's a completely
independent thing so I can fact I wonder
if this works I can introduce a local
for it and it's even decently named and
importantly that's that's one off the
end of whatever you apply it to it's not
sort of relative to right next in this
case right so you could use its notion
of one from end that's independent of
the length of the thing you eventually
applied to and then we have a notion of
ranges which for for substring it would
be really nice if we had an overload
that took the actually there's a bug
here right it should have you set - -
okay this program because that just to
show how like how you easily is to be
off by one you want to chop off one at
either end yeah but since you're saying
the length of the result here it should
have been two shorter than the length of
the original thing but it would have
been easier if there was an overload
that took an index at the end there but
there isn't but there's something even
better which is an overload that takes a
range so range expressions with dot dot
between two indices which can either be
an int or had int right and they're
independent so we could do range of one
two three yes
could do range of hat three to hat one
yeah is you know the last ignore the
last character but the two characters
before it and of course it's composable
so I can reuse that index that I have up
there and it's and it still becomes from
end and that's a shoe there's a
shorthand for leaving off on that end
and that means hat zero mm-hmm that
means the end all the way to the end and
if you leave off in the beginning that
means from that means zero right so and
of course combining ranges and indexes
now really becomes nice right there two
independent features but if you combine
them you get something that's very nice
and looks like what other languages have
so you can imagine and we could kind of
sort of hacked it up if you put the
right source code behind which I think
you did that in the prototype you can
try it we have an index or on text that
takes a range now you can you can
substring just by applying an index or
in a range expression so like this was I
think was the original exam right okay
and that would work not just for Strings
but then for any span and anything that
influenced it appropriately and probably
raised we would return spans when your
substrate or when you when you slice
those this is essentially for slicing
right cool anyway I want to do something
slightly so we've been talking about the
future of c-sharp to a language two or
two minutes yeah the future of what's in
the language I want to point out a
couple of things about the future of
where you can use the language so one of
these mats has seen and one he hasn't so
as you know I write the note of time
library and it's been a source of
frustration to me that the notice time
website is very static it's very you
know here's the stuff so I've been
working with the tri-dot net team to
embed a live coding environment in the
know design website and today it's
somewhat works okay so we have some
things here I can say right get the
current zone date/time and we have
intellisense assuming that the network
connections working yeah so I can find
out what what properties are in my zone
date
and I can run the code and it's showing
now you'll notice showing the 10th of
June because this is cached any time
that you run stuff with trade net if it
notices you've got the exact same source
code as a previous execution it'll
return you that result now earlier on
this wouldn't work and it's it's
possible that this has been fixed behind
the scenes with my friends in the trade
out net team it's also possible that it
hasn't and Wow I didn't expect it to
completely all right there we go
right so I think this has given a 503 on
the back end it will be fixed oh no well
it's worked Thank You Diego or whoever
it was that fixed it for me so this was
running live code and the idea is I have
some recipes here you know you can find
out how old I am just copy that to the
editor edit it there the actual the web
design part is nothing to do with the
tri-dot net team which is why it's awful
because this is my web design skills are
non-existent but again you know you can
run the code and it will say that it's
nearly my 42nd birthday so that's is
running c-sharp in a cloud container
somewhere but you get to edit the
c-sharp code live in the browser and the
other what I think is very cool way of
running code bom-bom-bom and this is
taking more conference Wi-Fi than I
would like and is running c-sharp in the
browser itself so for example suppose we
want to find out more information about
the Copenhagen timezone because though
yeah we're in the ha I shouldn't travel
so much so in Oslo we can and I'm very
new to this this is all something called
blazer and this was hacked together over
the last few days or so and we've got
all this stuff coming this is not on a
server
I could disconnect from the Wi-Fi and
still do stuff I can do this on my phone
this is running c-sharp via webassembly
via mono that is in JavaScript slash
webassembly interpreting the IL from the
Noda time assembly so when you think
about the future of languages don't
think in terms of the future features
within the language but where are you
going to be able to run it next and I'm
sure basically any future language will
be designed so it can run pretty much
anywhere it's the old Microsoft logo all
right where do you want to run today
right yeah and so I think that's pretty
awesome and I wanted to this is the very
first time of showing trade net on the
notice home website which is something
I've been excited about for a few months
now so that's all we have time for we'll
probably be around the front packing up
and things if you want to come and ask
us questions thank you very much thank
you and what I should have said